TRACY, ARTIE FUQUA AND JERMAINE
REMAIN IN THE HOSPITAL.
>> Reporter: ACTOR TRACY MORGAN
IS IN CRITICAL CONDITION AFTER A
DEADLY CAR CRASH ON ATE NEW
JERSEY TURNPIKE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
MORGAN SAID THE FORMER STAR IS
RESPONSIVE IN NEW BRUNSWICK, NEW
JERSEY WHERE HE'S BEING TREATED
FOR BROKEN RIB, A BROKEN NOSE
AND LEG.
AROUND 1:00 A.M. SATURDAY,
MORGAN WAS RIDING IN A LIMO VAN
AFTER FORMING AT A CASINO IN
DELAWARE.
STATE POLICE SAY MORGAN'S
VEHICLE WAS STRUCK FROM BEHIND
BY A WALMART TRACTOR TRAILER
THAT FAILED TO OBSERVE
SLOW-MOVING TRAFFIC.
THE IMPACT FLIPPED MORGAN'S
VEHICLE ON ITS SIDE, KILLING ONE
PERSON AND INJURING SEVERAL
OTHERS.
>> ALL I KNOW I SAW TRAFFIC AND
I STOPPED AND I WAS UPSIDE DOWN.
>> Reporter: MORGAN'S FRIEND AND
FELLOW COMEDIAN JAMES McNAIR,
KNOWN AS JIMMY MAC DIED IN THE
CRASH.
>> DEVASTATED, JAMES, I LOVE
YOU.
>> Reporter: POLICE ARRESTED
35-YEAR-OLD KEVIN ROPER, A
WALMART EMPLOYEE AND DRIVER OF
THE TRACTOR TRAILER.
CHARGING HIM WITH ONE COUNT OF
DEATH BY AUTO AND FOUR COUNTS OF
ASSAULT BY AUTO.
WALMART'S CEO RELEASING A
STATEMENT SAYING IN PART, WE ARE
PROFOUNDLY SORRY THAT ONE OF OUR
TRUCKS WAS INVOLVE
IF IT'S DETERMINED THAT OUR
TRUCK CAUSED THE ACCIDENT,
WALMART WILL TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON SUNDAY, TRACY MORGAN'S
REPUBLIC LA SIFT NOTED HIS
RECOVERY WOULD BE A LONG ONE.
>> MORGAN'S REP TELLS US HE DID
HAVE SURGERY ON HIS BROKEN LEG.
HE ALSO BROKE HIS NOSE.
HE'S NOT BROKEN RIBS.
HE'S EXPECTED TO BE IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR SEVERAL MORE WEEKS.
THE DRIVER OF THAT LIMO SAID HE
HEARD TRACY SCREAMINGING AFTER
THE CRASH, BUT HE COULDN'T REACH
HIM.
ALONG WITH